so most people write their business plan
for the following year in the month of
december however
if you no longer look at that business
plan
after february you stopped looking at it
you didn't write a business plan
you simply wrote a wish list today i'm
going to talk about the 206 people make
when it comes down to writing their
business plans
and i'm gonna give you a pdf on exactly
how you can write your business plan for
2021.
[Music]
so look there's three different types of
people when it comes down to business
planning there are the wingers
the thinkers the doers the wingers they
just wing everything they do they're not
really going to put a lot of time into
business planning
and everything they do in their lives is
kind of like wishful thinking this is
why i said that
at the beginning most people don't look
at their business plan after february
because it was just a wish list right
then you have the thinkers you have the
doers my goal
is for you not to just be a thinker
thinker are those that actually do the
timing and look at it
and then doers are the ones that execute
what they thought about
to get their business plans together
i've been doing business plans now since
2002.
it used to be very weak it used to be
just regular stuff i would write on a
piece of paper hoping to be a great year
and then i wouldn't hit 80 of goals and
i got better and better and better
2016 i shared with many of you the one
page business plan if you haven't
downloaded it yet
i'll give it to you at the end of the
pdf here's what it looked like you're
looking at it at the screen
and one of the things i talked about on
the business planning is the fact that
you can't just look at a business plan
as a business
plan it's a life plan you have to look
at it from your personal
standpoint your financial your health
your spiritual
if you have an aching tooth that you got
something going on with your mouth with
your teeth
that's bothering you and you're sitting
down at appointments and you're annoyed
you're probably not going to do a good
job that you're
because there's a pain there's a pain in
your back there's a pain somewhere
your health is a part of it you're if
you're heavier you gain 50 pounds
it's going to affect your business if
your marriage isn't good relationships
aren't good
mom dad brothers sis you got issues that
are bothering you
spiritual all of that come together so i
challenge folks to be looking at their
business plan
as a life plan matter of fact when you
get involved with some of these higher
end
ceo groups you pay 15 20 000 per year
you know what are the things all the
ceos talk to each other about they go up
on the board
and they write down in my business life
i'm a 10 right now in my personal life
i'm a two right now
in my financial life i'm a seven right
now am i health i'm a four
right now i'd like to talk to you guys
about my personal life or my marriage
and he says
we're going through a divorce my wife
told me last week she wants to leave me
and we spend one hour talking about
divorce amongst 12 other ceos
because those who build a big business
realize your business plan
has a lot to do with your life and
everything else you do so i wrote that
one page business plan last year
i gave to you how i think going into a
new year and i shared with you a few
different things which i'll put the link
for it as well for you to
go through we talked about in 2019 i
said 20 how to prepare for 2020 with
strategies
i said number one first to look at 2019
recap what you went through study your
trends all this other stuff the good bad
ugly
then i said looking at potential 20 20
threats
i didn't put pandemic in here this tells
you i've never been through it so i
don't put pandemic but i said industry
politics economy regulation family held
personal
anticipate expected events in your
company
third i wrote after having looked at
your threads you should be looking at
things to anticipate
they could include the following new
hires new products new comp plan all
that others the next 15 moves
then i said after having looked at
threats and business opportunities it is
important to shift to looking at numbers
to month quarter quarter then i said
next would be a list of topics to follow
closely in 2020
and the topics are trade war 5g brexit
election u.s iran
epstein this is what i said last year
right pandemic hadn't hit yet this video
was shot
and was live november 12th i believe
2019 is when it went live
then i said people to follow here's what
i sent the video last year on what
people to follow in the year of 2020.
look at the list of nine names i give in
the video exactly a year ago
so you notice the names trump obviously
trump there was a lot of things in 2020
i have to do with trump
warren biden biden president-elect
hillary kushner kushner uae uh
uh israel bezos i mean dominated
he was all over the place musk 90
billion dollars he made in six months
dorsey
controlled election with the new york
post because i knew how much control
he and zach had you had to watch him and
zuck what they did
to control the election the influence of
the election and that was for last year
right
list of names and then at the end i
talked about calendar i went through the
whole thing with calendar so
everything i said about the video last
year
still applies for this year all of it i
said last year
applies for this year but i got a new
list of names
for people to follow this year and i got
20 mistakes you can make at the end of
the video i'll give you my new list of
names to follow for 2020.
one but here's some of the mistakes
people make when it comes onto business
planning number one
there is no quiet time meaning they
don't have a quiet time
where they turn off the kids the wife
the husband the family
friends the phone everything and you go
into a cave
and you sit there by yourself and you
start thinking
you look at everything that happened in
the prior year and you think
not one hour not two hours not three
hours this is an
all-day event for you on a saturday or
on a sunday
away from everybody you gotta plan this
you can't wing it it's not one of those
things where you go ink
and preferably lots of papers lots of
data
lots of numbers lots of everything 2003
was the first year i started tracking
every single thing with my
finances november 18th is when i started
tracking everything
and the reason why i started tracking it
on the 18 was my credit score was 484
495 499 okay
and if you watch the video the life of
an entrepreneur in 90 seconds
you see a credit report that's my credit
report and credit score from 2004.
it's the original credit report score
that i got in 2004.
so every 18th i had my checking account
my saving account my investment my
stocks
my mutual funds my artifacts my
collectibles my cards
everything that i had and my credit
score at the bottom i tracked all of it
every 18 it would update every 18 would
update every 18 would update and i did
that
religiously guess what happened to the
credit score went from 484 to 495 499
to 820 822 798 and the rest is history
why
because quiet time led to measuring
my data so the second mistake people
make is they don't have their data
around them they don't measure their
data
you got to have like for me everything
to me is now about data
i want stats i want numbers i want
everything to look at
this year over last year because if i
can look at the history of the numbers
that i've done how can i predict what's
going to happen
if i don't look back how can i predict
where we're going to be going
if i can't look back and see what things
happen last year how can i say the month
of january we're going to do this in the
month of february we're going to do this
and the month of march we're going to be
doing this
i can't do it so one quiet time go
together and start thinking about what's
going to happen number two gather all
your data number three
is sitting there the mistake a lot of
people make with their business plan
is they overestimate what they're going
to do that
that year they overestimate and i think
gates was the the one that said
many people overestimate what they can
do on one year and
underestimate what they can do in 10
years let me repeat that one more time
most people overestimate what they can
do in one year and
underestimate what they can do in 10
years what does this mean to most people
overestimating
they'll sit there and they'll say this
year i'm going to make a million dollars
and the most money they've ever made is
fifty thousand dollars how are you gonna
go 20 x from 50
to a million dollars good you're being
optimistic don't get me wrong it's good
you're excited about it
but what was your december what did you
show in the month of december
and what kind of momentum are you going
into a new year today i'm going to make
a million dollars
to go from 52 million dollars that's
going from 4 000 a month income to 83
000 all your income
that's you're overestimating so what
happens is the more you overestimate
your goals
you eventually stop taking business
plans seriously
rather sitting there and saying well i
think you know i'd like to be here
and what is it that i can do this year
if i did a hundred thousand dollars this
i think if we push i can get to 500 000
because we have a lot of momentum going
on right now but i know for a fact we
can get to 250. i know for a fact we can
get to a number like this
so if you don't look at the day if you
don't have quiet time if you don't look
at your data
if you don't look at your numbers and
realistically make some numbers i'm not
talking about not being positive
but tesla's been around for a while yes
musk made 90 billion dollars this year
in six months or seven months
but how long ago was it when everybody's
seen tesla's going out of business
tesla's going out of business that's
what's going out of business
amazon may be worth what it's worth
today two trillion dollars whatever the
number may be
and bezos may be worth 200 billion
dollars today but do you remember how
many times on the calls he would do
and investors would say where are the
dividends where the dividends everybody
else is paying dividends but you're not
paying dividends and basos would say
on his earnings call i've told you if
you want or dividends i'm not the guy
but if you want to believe me long term
10 20 years from now i promise you i'm
going to make you a lot of money
guess what the first group of people
that he gave 20
to and they gave him a million dollars
you know what that 20 is worth today
400 billion dollars what do you think
you think the people that were patient
are happy they were patient
yes the ones that were not patient
they're somewhere telling a story to
their kids and grandkids
honey your grandpa should be worth a
billion dollars today but he's not
there's an element of being patient so
quiet time
data underestimate overestimate don't
make that mistake
actually based on the data be able to
put a better number on what you can do
the following year number four is not
knowing what numbers to measure here's
what i mean by what
numbers to measure look there's a lot of
different data that you're going to have
a lot of
data points i mean i have hundreds of
thousands of data points that i can look
at you know
what we sell you know but there is
the most important data to measure
this is why john doe wrote a book
measure what matters okay and
when steve jobs died everybody went to
john doerr's house to
reflect on the life of steve jobs and
john doerr in his book
measure what matters talks about okrs
and the whole idea about okrs
is what is the most important data that
you got to measure for you
when you're doing business planning
you're sitting around saying what do i
do
the movie moneyball the guy eventually
figures that the most important data in
baseball
it's not rbis not hits it's not home
runs it's not tickets sold it's not any
of that stuff it's
on base percentage he found that the
most important one biggest mistake
people make going into new year is
if you don't know the most important
data point that you need to grow your
business
how are you even going to make any kind
of proper guesstimation of what you're
going to do you don't because you don't
yet know
the most important data to measure so
you got to sit there with your quiet
time and say
what is really the most important date
is it sales is it calls is it context is
it budget is it advertising is it who we
hire is it
the talents ability is what is it is it
number of sales people is a number of
phone calls there's a number of outreach
i don't know what it is you got to get
your data when we got our data my
business exploded
you got to sit there knowing exactly
what is the most important
measures uh uh uh to matter what is the
most important number for you
for for you to measure and then from
there it's game changers because you can
actually now predict better
on what you're going to do in the future
next one is simple it's research and let
me tell you why research is a very very
uh high paid skill for you to have and
very few people do it here's why
if i wouldn't have done research the day
everybody shut down nhl and be all this
others i would have panicked but because
i came back and i researched and i
looked at it and i said okay
let's see what the last 10 pandemics
have done and i looked at sars mers
ebola
aids every one of them and like okay the
market recovers within six to 12 months
ninety percent of the time i was calm i
shared that share that level of common
data with my
peers and the people i work with they
looked at the data okay pat this just
kind of makes sense well
listen guys there's a 90 chance this is
going to go away mark is going to
recover it's going to come back up to 30
000.
we're going to be all right market goes
down to 18
200 i'm staying calm 18 500 i'm staying
calm
the dow announces they're over what 30
000. but my level of calmness came
because i
did my own research i didn't rely on cnn
and fox you
when you want to do your business plan
for the following year you got to do
your own research don't rely on what the
media is telling you
you go do research on some of the areas
you need to be careful with
for 2021 so you know how to make that
proper audible and maneuver
and not be affected like the rest of the
people will be affected by
just because you decided to do some
research and they didn't all right so
the next mistake a lot of people may go
into new year's are following
they go into a new year with the same
exact skill sets they've had thinking is
plenty
in 2021 but it's not meaning if you
didn't know how to use zoom in 2019 well
you got screwed if you didn't know how
to use it in 2020 because you had to
learn how to use that skill set right
there are a certain set of skill set
that you got to learn how to use in 2021
that you don't have right now you don't
know how to do it right now could be a
lot of different things
you may not be a good recruiter you may
not be good at the retaining people you
may not be good at selling you may not
be good at negotiating you may not be
good at raising money you don't even
know what it is to raise money you don't
know the different
you know measures that people put and
say well here's how we're going to
control we're going to put the controls
on this
you don't know any of this stuff but
guess what all of those things are
available you can go buy the books from
other people that have done it
and you can improve yourself and those
skill sets so when going into a new year
as excited as people are about the
numbers you're going to ask who do i
need to be
to do 10 million this year i've only
done 2 million who do i need to be
to do a million this year the most i've
ever done is 200 000 and what skill sets
do i need make a list of three to five
skill sets
go order every single book on those
topics with 500 plus reviews on amazon
immerse yourself on those topics take
courses whatever you can
just to get better at those few
different skills because if you don't
20 19 20 20 20 21 20 22 everything's
gonna be the same because
until you decide to add some new skill
set for new times and not a lot gonna
change
this next one's gonna be a simple one
but it's something you gotta be thinking
about a lot look cash you need cash no
matter what anybody says cash is not
king cash is king
i understand ray dalio says cash isn't
king he's talking about just putting
your money in cash and not investing it
i'm talking about
you having cash to be able to move you
having cash in case of emergency taking
place
you having cash in case the government
does another shutdown and
there's a new administration they're not
aggressive they're very they they
actually want to
be complete opposite trump wanted to
open up the economy biden's going to
lock it down biden's going to get people
everybody wearing masks they're going to
want to get people six weeks to not
really go to work and stay home maybe
that's going to be
eight weeks 10 weeks 12 weeks if you
don't have cash
and the senate is controlled by the
right the house is controlled by the
left
the stimulus is not going to be three
and a half trillion dollar stimulus that
they wanted to go out
they can't because they got to get
through senate depending on what happens
in georgia
which means what the two two point
whatever trillion dollar stimulus that
we send where the economy came back
up that was approved by both sides when
that money went back out
this time around if you don't have cash
you may be affected by it
so you got to make sure you have a big
big emphasis in 2021
of increasing the amount of cash you
have
so you can make pivots and decisions and
you're not controlled
by what a complete new regime could do
in america all right so next point
here's a very important one look
none of us were expecting a pandemic in
2020 you got a beautiful year 2020
everything was nice the number 20 20
vision 2020
dubai is going to do 2020 expo they've
been planning for 10 years
they spent billions of dollars expecting
millions of people to go to dubai to see
what this expo is going to be
pandemic kids everything got cancelled
you know the 2020 wasn't 20 20 olympics
or
you know it's it's a i don't know
everybody forgot if it's supposed to be
olympic year
everybody forgot about it no one even
thought about it
everything got canceled everything got
postponed
so if you got hit hard by the pandemic
and you were shocked and it was
surprised fine it's the first time
you and i can be surprised the first
time but second time around if you get
hit
by the same exact thing and you were not
prepared for it it's no longer a shocker
you didn't prepare for it meaning you
have to be ready
for a lot of different weird things to
happen in 2021 not as saying it's going
to happen
i don't know if it's going to happen but
you got to go out there and study
what are the biggest surprises or
setbacks i can have in business what are
they
how will i react to it one of them you
need to have a standard operating
procedure on how to react when there's a
next pandemic in shutdown
with your staff with your clients with
your employees with your partner with
your vendors with schooling with your
kids
put everything because it could most
likely happen again
in 2021 but if it happens again you
cannot get caught
it's not 2020 anymore let me tell you
why this is a subtle one but it's a very
powerful one i have a lot of people that
i mentor around the country around the
world and
one of the things i notice is people's
reward punishment
program is fully out of whack and here's
what i mean by it
i see people that reward themselves
their families their peers their sales
people without any kind of earning
and what do i mean by this i've always
gone
off of a reward punishment program
meaning
i went to new york i said if i cross six
figure your income i'm gonna go to new
york because i wanna watch the ball drop
and i wanna be there on new year's eve
you know what i did i went there
i said if i have a hundred thousand
dollars i'm gonna go to guatemala with a
friend of mine and i'm gonna go give
away bibles and all this other stuff and
went to guatemala city i had a great
time in guatemala
my buddy leo wanted to give away bibles
we went there had a great time it was
phenomenal i went there from december
26th day after christmas
to december 30th four days we went to uh
you know uh puerto barrios livingston we
went all over the place grand
hague which was a beautiful place all
the water volcanoes had a great time
then i said if i have a quarter million
dollars in savings i'm gonna go buy
myself a harley davidson got a quarter
million dollar in savings
i went to the dealership i've never
ridden a motorcycle before a friend of
mine god bless the soul is no longer
with us anymore
i call jim jim ride the motorcycle he
brought it to my office
at 11 o'clock at night i learned how to
ride a motorcycle
five minutes afterwards i was on the
freeway going 100 miles an hour not
recommending it i'm just telling you
what i did right
but everything's been about reward and
punishment so guess what happened my
kids
everything's about reward and punishment
people come to my house and they'll see
on the wall 200 books that my son's
already finished oh this one eight years
old
and then they'll see my youngest one is
at about 40 books or 30 books right now
that he's going through and my
daughter's going to go through it as
well
and they say how do you get your kids to
read books how do you do it
i can't can you talk to my kids i'm like
can i talk to your kids
i don't need to talk to your kids i need
to talk to your kids parents why
here's why i'm at neiman mark is
shopping my middle one dylan is
wrestling all over my head okay climbing
all
we love doing this stuff together here
and i right
the lady looks at me she says oh my gosh
that's so sweet i remember when my kids
were that age i'm like oh cool how many
of you guys she tells me you guys
what are they doing now their doctor
they're this their lawyer i'm like dang
you raise them good yes
three tips on parenting we're sitting
right there she's watching her husband
get changed
she says uh um i'll give you one tip i
won't give you three of them i said
what's that
she says you know when you ever threaten
your kids and you tell them if they
don't do this you're not going to get
ice cream or whatever i said yeah what
about it
when you threat them keep your word i
say why it's just because if you don't
they won't believe you again what a
freaking powerful thing she said to me
what so meaning we're going to somewhere
i tell my daughter
if you don't do that i thought i'm not
going to buy you ice cream i have to
keep it as much as i want to give her
ice cream that day
and i have to keep it it's very hard to
do when it comes down to your own
rewards and punishment don't reward
yourself
if you don't hit the whole goal do not
do it you are weakening yourself
and don't do it if the company your team
or your family also doesn't hit it
with that mindset going into new year
you will work twice as hard to hit your
goals
and when you earn them it'll feel so
good
when you earn them okay so this next
one's got a lot of power behind it
it's about cutting the fat with some
people
in your life let me explain to what i
mean by this you gotta unfollow certain
people go on your instagram again your
twitter account go and see who you
follow
unfollow some of them and i'm not
talking about unfollow
oh i don't agree with them politically i
follow obama i follow trump
i follow i follow people on all sides
not talking about political
or opposition i'm talking about people
in your life that are negative
that are toxic you got to eliminate
those people out of your life
you got to sit there and say um who do i
talk to the most this year
let me see is the most negative people
in my life that are sucking the best
out of my life my energy who are they
that cousin i'm sorry bobby i love you
we're not gonna have a relationship
together anymore like we used to i can't
talk to anybody as much as we did i'm
cutting you
every year i've cut the fat it's the
hardest thing to do
and it gets easier and easier as you age
and by the way the results and the
reward becomes
bigger and bigger as you age because the
compounding effect so you got to make a
list of people you got to cut i know you
don't want to do it you got to cut some
fat
this you know i'm not talking about just
fatty i'm talking about fat is in your
relationship and people around you
because they're holding you back here's
the next one when you write a business
plan here's a mistake people make
they'll go to the smallest thinking
people and say what do you think about
my business plan
oh it's impossible oh i don't like it oh
i hate it oh it's great oh it's awesome
oh it's amazing
why get the council of small thinkers on
your business plan
go to somebody that's going to talk to
you and it's going to hold you
accountable to your business plan and
critique you and say i don't know about
this i don't know about this you sure
about this
why'd you write this what's this all
about i don't understand this part
how do you come up with this number how
did you come up with this formula how
did you come up with this number
and you all of a sudden are going to sit
there and like oh my gosh this is
uncomfortable i don't want to be able to
talk to somebody that's going to
ask me how to come up with the number on
how i'm going to make a million dollars
in 2021 yes how'd you come up with the
math
well i just thought you know it's kind
of a number because if i double it twice
and if i
guys give me like are you writing a real
business plan or wish list i'm writing a
business plan this is not a business
plan you're wishing for this to happen
it ain't going to happen you got to go
back to realizing what's going to happen
with your business plan not something
like this so don't share your business
plan with small thinkers go sit down
with somebody that's going to be tough
with you
honest with you gentle with you
respectful with you
but is willing to challenge you and
you'll be able to find
leaks in your business plan that others
will not tell there's gonna be a lot of
your mom or dad or brother and sister
some of them are gonna be like oh my
gosh it's so awesome
you don't need that you need somebody
that knows what they're talking about
that's going to give you direct counsel
all right so when it comes down to
business planning a lot of times people
spend way too much time thinking about
their competitors okay
competitors constant competition for me
i got to tell you
um you know if you work with me in the
insurance company
and you ask the people that work
directly with me how often does pat
measure and talk about other competitors
other companies and they'll tell you
i'd be more than happy for you to ask
them and they'll tell you pat never
talks about competitors
he doesn't bring them up and say well
this is what they're doing this is what
they're doing that's what they're doing
i don't sit there and say we gotta go
beat them we gotta no i know what people
are doing because i know the market i'm
not telling you i don't look at the
market of course i know what's going on
with the markets i have to study the
market
i'm responsible as a seo and a founder
to be thinking about that
but uh i look at things that we
need to be improving when i was small
and i was looking one of the competitors
i'm gonna look at that
as one of the mistakes people make is
this is two in one because sometimes
you compare yourself to a person that's
got 20 years experience on you you can
that's not a good thing to do because
you're going to get this discouraged
there's no way i can beat him he's 20
years ahead of you
she's 15 years ahead of you right that's
a mistake people make but you ought to
be inspired by your competition where
they're at because if you're willing to
do the work
and improve that could be you one day
but sometimes people spend way too much
time on the outside
of what everybody else is doing and way
too little time on what you need to be
doing what you need to improve and not
everybody else
they don't make or break you yes they
wake up every morning hoping to put you
out of business
don't think i'm telling you they're
sweethearts and they're nice people and
they love you
and they want all your dreams to become
a reality they want your dreams to
become a reality as long as you take
no market share away from them go take
it from other people they're okay with
that but as long as you're in their
industry they don't want you to grow as
fast as you're growing
they'll say all the nice things to you
in your face but behind closed doors
they're saying i'd love to whoop his ass
and put him out of business
that's normal the way you beat that and
defeat that
is you focus on we got a leak here we
got to improve here we got to get better
here
the more you stay in that mindset
eventually things will work itself out
because odds are the people you're
competing with right now are not big
enough anyways you really got to get
used to competing with some of the
bigger dogs you're not there yet all
right so the next one is uh your
calendar you don't do a calendar people
just do business plan and they don't do
a calendar they don't know what's going
on january
versus take out a calendar and kind of
see what's going on general what events
do i have in january what travel time do
i have with the
family what am i doing what's the kid's
birthday where's my everything
write it down christmas thanksgiving
what do you celebrate and then
conventions conferences i'm going to go
to this i'm going to go to that election
whatever that's going on
have all of that written out in your
calendar when does the close out if you
have a close-up your close outs on
thursday
what date does it fall on what date does
31st fall on does it follow on sundays
saturdays what day is a good day for you
to be closed out
i look at all of those dates together
month week
quarter year and then i start coming
back and saying well i'm going to do
this and this court i'm going to do this
and this month i'm going to do this in
this month i'm going to do this and this
week every one of those things is part
of you
strategizing by writing out your
calendar while you're doing your entire
business plan
very few as weird as it sounds very few
people look at their calendar when
they're doing their business planning
it's a big mistake people make
this next one's probably in my top five
list every year it's who i need to
recruit i know a lot of people don't
think about this for me it's all about
recruiting right now i got a long list
of people i'm recruiting
low-level mid-level c-suite executives
new chairman of the board
new investors i'm i'm recruiting so many
people right now
circle of people i need to be around
different types of people i'm trying to
get into different
communities i'm trying to get into and
it's all about recruiting you're trying
to recruit
friends you're trying to recruit an
assistant you're trying to recruit
you're trying to recruit advisors mentor
everything
is about recruiting so you got to sit
there and think about who you want to
recruit i want to recruit a wife many
years ago you know you're trying to
recruit a girlfriend a real steady
girlfriend
that's also part of recruiting last time
we're having dinner at the house on
thanksgiving and tikran
who's pretty much family to us him and
his wife morale he said something he
says in armenian they say something they
say you don't have a choice
on family you're born into family it's
not by choice
you don't you don't choose your mom and
dad you don't choose your brother and
sister
you don't choose your cousins you're
just in that family
he says but when it comes on to friends
you get to choose and many of the
friends you end up choosing become
family they end up becoming family to
you you also get to choose your friends
you get to choose who to recruit at this
next phase of your life
and this by far is one of the top five
most important things you got to do
going into a new year
and very few people think about who they
want to recruit going into a new year
every year needs a theme what do i mean
by every year needs a theme every year
needs a theme every single year needs a
theme you know a movie has a name right
rambo rocky gone with the wind you know
schindler's list
every every movie has a name its own
say here go watch it's a good movie go
watch it every year needs a new theme
you know you're in the year of
redemption the year of recovery do you
rather come back
the year of whatever the year of
creating wealth the year of creating
leaders the year of being a leader
whatever it is
every year needs a theme when you have a
theme you're emotionally connected to
that year for you
you got to have a theme i've had a year
of something something
since 2003. every year the year of
something and that's got to be something
for you to be thinking about
when it comes down to your theme so as
you're still sitting around doing your
thinking
and you're coming up with all the data
everything that you're doing words will
stick out
boom boom that's a people that's how
people come up with titles to books
right like your next five moves
originally was
solve for x and solve for y then it was
you know
uh uh all these other this your next 15
moves and your next five moves
everything's coming together
theme you got to come up with a theme
for next year and it gets you so excited
if it has a lot of meaning to it and
especially if you're excited
if you're married your husband and wife
are excited and your team gets excited
you're on top of the world
so you know how we talk about earlier
the life plan we talk about personal
financial health all this stuff in every
area you write down your next 5 10 15
moves every area
come up with your next 5 10 15 moves
health i want to get to 220 pounds i'm
260 right now
what's your next five moves to get there
marriage man i'm single i don't have a
girlfriend i've been on enough in a
relationship for the last six years i'm
sick of it i'm 29.
i'd like to find a real good girl great
what are your next five ten moves
to get i don't know number one maybe you
need to get your stuff in the right
place spiritual you gotta get clear on
who you're looking for number two
number three when you get clear who
you're looking for maybe you gotta get
some finances in order maybe you got to
go in the right place to meet the right
girls the places you're going to is you
know the wrong places
i got to find a better place then you
got to tell everybody what you're
looking maybe you're going to come up
with your moves right
but in every area of your life come up
with your next 5 10 15 moves
i guarantee you 99 of you watching this
will not do it only one percent of you
will
and fortunately 41 the world tends to
give you
what you want especially to those who
know clearly what they want i hope
that's you
this is a tough one and i'm also
hesitant about not sharing this with you
but i kind of have to share this with
you because
i don't know any other way but to kind
of tell you what's on my mind
and that is sometimes you got to cut the
wrong person out of your life especially
the last appointment that you have this
could be a boyfriend girlfriend i hope
you're not married because i do not
support any of this stuff when it comes
down to marriage and all that stuff but
if you're dating the wrong girl the
wrong boyfriend and you maybe even
engage and it's just not going the right
way
maybe it's time you've been in it for a
year two years three years you have a
vision this big
he or she has a vision this big you're
clashing you have to make your vision
this big for this relationship to work
and she or he is now willing to go like
this for you
just so you know it's not going to work
out i remember one time i'm talking to a
pastor of mine and we went to claim
jumpers this is with a guy named
pastor dudley and i was in a
relationship and i always tell him i
said you know here's what's going on
with this here's what he says look let
me just tell you this here
whatever you don't like about the person
you're with right now is going gonna get
worse it's gonna get bigger
if you don't like it can you live with
that i said no way in the world this is
not gonna get better it's just gonna get
worse just so you know that
boom that was ended that relationship
was very easy and it was
so hard to do so hard to do because
there was love there was fun there was
all of that
but both of us knew i wanted to live
this life
she wanted to live this life one of the
hardest things to do
one of the best things we ever did she's
happy i'm happy
yeah it's not an easy one to say but
your last appointment is holding you
back
not all of you some of you you got to
kind of move on so this next part is
only for those of you guys that have
people that report to you if you have
people that report to you
you got an additional step and here's
what it is so you got your preliminary
business plan that you write a business
plan is not just one that you write it
you write it you put time into it
and then two weeks later you're like
okay it's solid i'm good this is what
i'm going
to the bank with right then you during
that time you're doing business plan
with your key direct
reports or your key leaders and you do
business plan with them i said okay let
me see where this guy's oh he's not in a
good place oh she's definitely in a bad
place
they're having a bad relationship she's
not good okay i don't know what's going
to happen over here maybe i need to hire
somebody else
to help ride out the sun because she's
not a good season
then you're doing the business plan then
one of the people you sit down where
you're like
oh this guy's really trying to
accelerate his life in this next year
where is this guy going this changes the
game for your company remember a
company becomes a great company based on
the right people they hire and identify
and build
then all of a sudden you sit there and
say this guy can take the company or
next level the business plan
changes and adjusts could even go higher
could go lower or you need to hire
better people you know fire some of the
people but you got to do your business
planning to get a pulse of where your
people ride way before new year comes
around so
if you got direct reports you need to go
do business planning with all your
direct reports
to those of you that have direct reports
did you kind of skim together very
quickly
did you kind of write it down like okay
go by just so you know you got to
schedule time and go through your direct
reports and do their business plan
very very big i promise you most will
not do it
this is the last part of the business
plan the mistake people make you ready
here's the last mistake the mistake is
they come out with their numbers
they come up with their goals they come
out with their commitments you know what
they do
they keep it a secret and when you keep
it a secret what's the level of
accountability
nothing you are not held accountable
pressure is less it's okay if you don't
hit it
you don't feel like a disappointment if
you don't hit it so let's keep it a
secret
when you come out with a business plan
tell the world that put some pressure on
to you
what does that do you have to take it
more seriously and in a team
it's great to share pressure it's bad if
it's only on you
if you keep it a secret to yourself you
ain't sharing that pressure with anybody
but if you share it and say guys this is
what we want to do this year who's in
who thinks we can have this what part of
it can you do what part of it can you do
can i count on you on this can i count
on you can i count on this
now we're all sharing the pressure and
you've declared your intention
big mistake most people spend hours and
days writing their business plan
and then don't share it with anybody you
know what happens it creates this much
pressure for them
and others and that is why i said at the
beginning
if you don't look at your business plan
after the month of february it was not a
business plan it was a
wish list those are the 20 mistakes most
people make
when it comes down to doing business
planning so i promise you pdf and i
promise you some names
that i'll give you to be looking out for
to follow on you let me give you some of
the names here
these are not all of them i'll just give
you some of them that i have here and
you can do what you want to do with them
let me go through them number one
is uh trump jr i'd say watch
trump jr very very closely i think
sometimes when a
father gets hit let's say trump loses
and he concedes i don't know if he's
going to concede or not
and you have a son with that big of a
personality with a chip on his shoulder
he's going to want to do something i
don't know what it's going to be i have
a feeling this is going to be very
vocal uh season in 2021 with trump jr
and he's not going to be biden's
favorite person in 2021 i may be wrong
but i think that's what's going to be
one of the names nexus g
china watching very closely they're
probably going to be happy because a lot
of those tariffs are going to change
you're going to hear a lot more
conversations with china in my opinion
obviously biden kamala harris depending
on what's going to happen is it going to
finish this term or not
are we all of a sudden going to see
because when biden won if you notice
kamala didn't give any acceptance
speeches or nothing
she was all the way on the side biden
didn't even say kamala do you want to
say anything she was completely on the
other side
trump when he wanted to say pence you
want to say something said a couple
words
so this may be one of those situations
if all of a sudden you see more kamala
on tv
then biden it may be a sign that hey get
get used to all of a sudden kamala being
the president
because he's going to be 82 so watch
that part very closely
i think aoc is going to push a lot i
think aoc and democrats are going to
have a lot of wars
and there's going to be a lot of
division between aoc and the dems
because
biden is not showing anybody on the
cabinet side that he's choosing
uh he didn't choose elizabeth warren or
bernie sanders or aoc
maybe his message is i'm not going all
the way to the social side i'm glad you
guys helped us
to get elected but i'm not putting any
of you guys inside so
they're going to be upset they're going
like wait a minute we helped elect you
you don't want to support us so there's
going to be some kind of a division i
think this is going to be a big part of
it
watch michael ulster him uh he will be
more influential as influential as
potentially fauci i think he's going to
have some choices on what we're going to
be doing
with his job i think the rock may make a
move if he's ever had any kind of plans
of running for office which i think he
may have
you may see some kind of involvement
with him more this year to kind of
p you know start showing signs of it i
don't know he may do one of those
interviews that the rocked it with oprah
winfrey
where you know oprah winfrey said hey do
you have any plans of running for office
one day
he may do one of those with uh rogan he
may do one of those with allen he may do
one of those so
just kind of keep that part of him when
it happened i'm kind of letting you know
he may one day be the president of
the united states john roberts is
another one to watch uh
uh he may be very very important because
he may be republican
but he votes against republicans a lot
of the democratic
supreme court justices they always vote
democrat pretty much 99 percent of the
time
but john roberts doesn't he he goes left
as well sometimes
and so you're gonna have to watch him
because if they decided to pack the
court and some of the stuff that they do
he may have some involvement in that i'd
be watching powell closely because of
interest rates
supreme court justice going to be very
very important this uh this time around
2021 to watch
and i'm going to put lebron in there
because if lebron has any plans this is
where
the opening of blm involvement some of
that stuff his new spring kill media
i don't know he may somehow get in the
biden administration and do something
it may not be this time or maybe in the
next three years but he may be somebody
that's going to want to get involved
in those areas so having said that if
you want this whole thing in pdf
today what word do we want to use do you
want to use just 2021
text 2021 to 310-340-1132 again
310-340-1132 the number 2021
and we will send you back the business
plan all of it the one-page business
plan
the other one i told you about that i
created last year and the 20 mistakes
people make
for you to have as you're preparing for
your business plan and if you haven't
watched either of those videos the one
page business plan
or strategies going into 2020 i highly
recommend you click on either one of
these things
to watch and if you're not in the states
where you can't get texts go on the link
below subscribe to our newsletter
and we will email you all the notes of
the business plan take care everybody
bye
[Music]